said after the game james are you  surprised that  y'all never made a run at all i may have  run it all in in this one  which is not good enough um you know we  just we don't we don't  obviously chemistry talent law it's just  everything and it was clear  um like i said these last few games um  they just from the beginning of the game  they were just aggressive  uh veteran team obviously a championship  team and  um you know one of the best teams that  we have in this league  um you know i love this city um i  literally  you know i've done everything that i can  um  you know i mean this situation is crazy  you know it's something that i don't  think can be fixed so  yeah thanks